[موسيقى] لقد
كنت دائمًا مهتمًا بكيفية
عمل البشر والآلات معًا، أنا
ألكسندر ريبين وأنا فنان وعالم
روبوتات،
بدأت بحثي في ​​البحث عن
الروبوتات الاجتماعية، وهي روبوتات تحب
التحدث إلى الناس أو التفاعل معهم بطرق
مختلفة  من الطرق التي أحتاج فيها إلى المساعدة
عندما أعمل باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي، هناك العديد من
أنواع العمليات المختلفة، مثل إحداها
يمكن أن أقوم برعاية مجموعة بيانات،
وقد تكون الأخرى أقوم برعاية المخرجات
ثم التوسع من هناك،
لذلك يعد هذا تثبيتًا تفاعليًا
يسمح لزوار موقعي  أظهروا أنهم يصنعون
أعمالهم الفنية الخاصة فقط من خلال التعبير عن
خيالهم في الفضاء باستخدام
كب كيك، أسلوبي انتقائي بعض الشيء
وأعتقد الآن أن بعض أسلوبي مدفوع بالتعليقات التي
أحصل عليها من الذكاء الاصطناعي، وقد
شاهد الكثير من الأشخاص فن الذكاء الاصطناعي للتو
حس رقمي ولكنني كنت أرغب في
إدخاله إلى العالم المادي من خلال العمل
مع مصممي النماذج ثلاثية الأبعاد والعجلات
والنحاتين الذين يشاركون في ذلك الكثير من البشر
وهذه السلسلة بالنسبة لي مثيرة للاهتمام للغاية،
فقد عملت مع المعارض قبل
العديد من المتاحف والأنواع المختلفة
أعتقد أن أي شيء يمكن أن يكون فنًا
اعتمادًا على كيفية إدراك الناس للفن.
أود أن أرى فن الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكّن المزيد من الأشخاص من
التعبير عن أنفسهم
وأفكارهم، وأعتقد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي سيكون
قويًا كأداة لإثارة خيال
الأجانب